hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
I get asked almost all the time like
clockwork
what tablet I use the most what tablet I
use the most and to be honest I don't
really use tablets all that often but
when I do it's the Nexus 10 and this is
the Nexus 10 revisited it's been almost
five months since the Nexus 10 was
released and from my experience the
hardware has pretty much disappeared and
left only the software for me to focus
on and this is a good thing this is
definitely a very good thing the
hardware itself just the screen the
build quality the materials and the
design they just kind of disappear into
your hands and you're just left
interacting with and touching pure
Android I have a link right below the
like button on this video to my full
Nexus 10 review in which I rant and rave
about a lot of things but first and
foremost the display and how awesome it
is good news it's still awesome
everything from the graphics and the
websites and games and texts and apps in
the Play Store everything is all still
super crisp super sharp and that's
exactly what you'd expect out of a 2560
by 1600 display that gives you 300 PPI
on a tablet that is by far the highest
dpi on any tablet out there viewing
angles and brightness are pretty solid
you know they're probably among the top
four tablets again another thing that's
become subtly awesome though is the
thinness is a pretty powerful tablet yet
it manages to be one of the thinnest and
slimmest out there yet it still houses a
9,000 milliamp hour battery that lasts
for days on standby and can give you 4
to 5 hours of screen on time before
needing to recharge so that's enough to
watch a movie on a plane easily but
there is something else that Samsung was
brilliant with when they made this guy
and that's the speakers the front-facing
speakers these are huge I don't think I
could go back to rear firing speakers on
a tablet again front-facing just makes
sense for every use of a tablet I
wouldn't be surprised to see more phones
to take on the style now that the HTC
One has proved that it makes sense for
smartphones too and yes the speakers are
pretty loud and clear without any sort
of distortion which is pretty important
again for me if I'm watching a movie or
listening to music or just watching a
YouTube video or something
like that another thing about the design
though is the material on the back it is
way more important than you originally
think a lot of people don't talk about
this but part of the reason the iPad or
the iPad Mini can feel so awkward to
hold or you might slip while holding it
is that they're just smooth metal plates
on the back the Nexus 10 back is my
favorite material on the back of any
mobile device
it's polycarbonate it's a rigid plastic
hardened plastic that has a sort of a
soft touch feel that's just a little bit
grippy slash tacky on the back so you
can easily hold the weight of the Nexus
10 in one hand and it still feels
natural I think Google learned a lot
from the success of the Nexus 7 and how
well it is to hold that they decided to
use this sort of back and the back welds
on really nice and curves around to the
front and just just blends in with the
design well there's no other way to put
it it just blends in and works with the
Nexus tens design also speaking of
design the hardware itself has held up
pretty well to regular constant use and
one of the unique points is actually
these pogo pins at the bottom actually
switched to the Pogo pin charger instead
of microUSB and actually found that it
charges quite a bit faster so I do
recommend picking up one of these on
ebay or something if you can get in
Nexus 10 definitely check this out it's
quite a bit faster one last thing about
the hardware Google has been slacking on
Nexus accessories especially that
mysterious Smart Cover like accessory
some of you may or may not know the
Nexus 10 has a removable back or at
least up at the top you can take the
back off and there is supposed to be an
accessory that clips into the Nexus 10's
back and folds over and it has a nice
soft microfiber on inside and multiple
color options basically a Smart Cover
like accessory for the Nexus 10 the
Nexus 10 even has magnets inside that
sleep and wake the display it is just
begging for an accessory like this as a
companion but as of right now in March
five months after release it's still
m.i.a come on Google either way we've
already seen Android 4.2.2 jelly bean in
action and there still might not be all
that many optimized apps in the world
for this device but I'll go ahead and
show you how I use Android on the Nexus
10 as a daily driver for my own purse
life alright so even though the Nexus 10
isn't really a consumer oriented device
I happen to use it personally as my
media consuming device pretty much bring
it everywhere to consume media which for
me consists of videos and news so you
can tell basically by my setup here and
I'll go through my home screens of the
Nexus 10 that it is a pretty simple
setup here like we said there's not a
whole lot of tablet apps going on here
so I'll go ahead and start from the
middle in the center here I have the
Google keep widget and the Google Drive
widget and that's it and I have a
calendar widget on the left
Falcon Pro which is my Twitter app
retinues and eye on the sky eye on the
sky is a pretty sweet weather app by the
way it's a definitely a good-looking one
and then over on the far left is just an
open empty screen and go ahead and throw
that wallpaper link down in the
description below the like button for
those of you who want to pick that up
then one to the right we have the Google
Play widgets here just for recommended
apps and recommend it on play and then
furthest to the right I have some sound
identifiers but that's basically it now
I have a Google now search widget up top
because that's basically locked there
but I always use Google now by swiping
up from the home screen I found that
that's my favorite way to access Google
now on any next device and or any device
however for that matter with software
keys so I always swipe up from the
bottom did you get to Google now and I
use Google now all the time I have a
separate video on how I use Google now
so if you want to watch that that's
where I have all that information there
and then most importantly down on the
bottom of the dock here are my most
frequently used apps so I have Google
now which again I use quite a bit but if
I don't want to swipe out from the
bottom
I will just tap that I've Google+ which
I use all the time Google Calendar
feedly that used to be Google Reader but
now I use feedly to keep up with the
news and I found that it's a
surprisingly good alternative slash
replacement for Google readers so that's
what I use to catch up on articles and
stuff throughout the day then on the
right side I have Google Tasks I have a
YouTube here when the YouTube app on
tablets is pretty good I use that pretty
much every day
there's also pocket which is basically
read it later I throw things in here
that I don't really have time for
necessarily immediately and then Dolphin
Browser that also used to be a Google
product Google Chrome but I found in
Dolphin Browser performs better on the
Nexus 10 so there you go guys those are
my reasons at least for choosing the
next
and over a lot of other tablets that I
could be using to do the same thing the
Nexus 10 does a lot of people like to
ask the question also Nexus 10 or iPad 4
or transformer pet a lot of them are
really high-end tablets with high
resolutions that are pretty similar and
I picked the Nexus 10 because number one
I like the back material better like I
said that polycarbonate is pretty
awesome number two it's sixteen by nine
which kind of rolls the iPad out
immediately but it still keeps the
transformer pad in and then it is the
highest resolution tablet on the market
today and since I'm a pixel person
that's really what got me so I really I
really think it's a great bang for the
buck a lot of people go with the Nexus 7
because it's also great bang for the
buck and it's a great 7 inch form factor
but Nexus 10 does it for me so leave
your thoughts below what do you guys
think about the Nexus 7 you can see me
down in the comments below replying
right below the like button on this
video but definitely give your thoughts
and opinions and we could talk about it
either way thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you guys in the very next video
you